dink-dink get up
dink get luggage okay
but God was mad like this can you might
have here no we didn't my life spikes
not manhandling it welcome back to the
Jenna and Julian podcast stop
I had to position it right thought by
moving it in a circle
oh I have to calibrate it okay
someone said the genitive podcast with
the dr. Phil theme song playing except
every time doing touches it might hit
Mike it gets louder just going one year
for you yes look at the judge on a
podcast so we have to regulate
everything ourselves
boy you beg you back on the floor
acoustics is over I'm going to go I'm
gone okay that's very goes better these
knots are is brought to you by the skin
you are not currently dominating your
cover see how it makes it we will Julian
okay that's a nope it's where Joe you're
not currently dominating your
conversation don't work but you could be
with the skin the chilling renewed water
that goes right to your email inbox and
all the top stories it does it see all
you're gonna do is to shred oh yeah I
described every morning concisely
baggage you know all the time of your
story in the world from your email inbox
they're going to go to the skin set the
th es kfk IMM comm slash Jenna doing and
you sign up right now get entered for a
chance to and $250 Visa gift card you
can spend on anything but especially
stuff but we'll see you later podcast
stick around folks also received by the
tracker guys
let's get rid of that ritual you have
looking for your keys before you go
because the tracker is a tiny little
coin size tracking device that you can
keep track of all your important things
with right now
go to the tracker that's th e TR ACK our
comm promo code gen Julian you get 20%
off you got to get one okay and trackers
30 30 day money-back guarantee means
you'll have a little is literally
nothing and if you keep it you'll lose
nothing trail anyway welcome I catch
your breath actually drink some of this
what is with you I don't have you mean
you just went like this you moved you my
guy certainly willing this will move the
whole podcast table menu ASMR slurp
dirty silly Dave nothing's with me
welcome back has been doing like I do it
I don't know if you noticed this tune
but someone sent me a utopia hat that
I'm wearing currently I have noticing
Jay sent it to the peel box and it said
that this was one of the original hats
from the show given to the crew that has
now been passed on to me and I have to
say it is probably among my favorite
possession um shots on utopia ho I would
say why don't you cry about it but
you're already doing that mm-hmm hold on
a second where you going okay Sharon oh
yes right now frame everything fine it's
all good shouts out to your utopia hat
and the person that sends it to your
pretty great it's pretty cool all I see
those is orange floating letters I don't
see any hat oh did you okay hey can you
scoot over a little bit I feel a little
bit crowded
[Laughter]
you can come back in I don't know not to
be given you told me to like get away
from you so I'm over here - okay you
spilled that on your pants they don't
need another chewing Jesus nasty nada
enchilada I'm not being in control
you're being nasty and out of control
the promise believe me am NOT okay
Julian I'm a bar go okay Julian wakes up
in the running to the time I was
standing over me you know the first
thing we wanted to talk about today was
the fact that Julian desperately wanted
to meet a cow or a pig which he's never
done before and he finally met one I did
it was a really really special day we
went to the gentle barn this morning you
live in the LA area or in the Missouri
area opening one of us are you should
check out really cool they say anything
for a bickering animal stage yeah I have
lived in California my whole life I've
taken many many many drives up to the up
the the state of California passing by
many farms seeing so many cows never
touched one never got up close to one
ever in my life and it's always been
something I really wanted to do why did
you want me to count Bob I guess it's
become something more on my to-do list
lately because I I've been eating
plant-based for you know the better part
of two years now and I I don't know
something about like I feel like it
would do something for me in person to
like actually hug account just pet em
and just realize like it's just a big
old dog you know what I mean it's just a
nice creature that just wants to live
its life anyway you know Jenna had
talked about gentle one for a long time
and we finally were like you know we
have a day off vote so let's go do it
so we did it today and uh man it was
special it was really nice and it was
such a weird experience to be honest
like there was there were so many
positives that I'm gonna take away and
never forget about today but then also I
just felt like the people who were there
we're just really bothering me I guess
like
first of all we didn't think there was
any that many people second of all why
do people have to act with such idiots
around animals I don't understand anyway
sorry was meeting the pigs and cows like
what you'd expected what did you expect
going in and and what it what was it
actually like um I expected them to be
sweet and like pets and kiss me I didn't
expect to like see all their
personalities and see how they all kind
of coexist just like just like a group
of dogs would do the same like we look
at dogs that you know have personalities
and in different little traits and are
cute for this reason and keep to that
reason and I never thought that that's
how you know cows would be so that's how
pigs would be and they were even the
goats were funny like it was very
interesting to see them all have their
own little thing they're all very very
characteristic has had even through the
sentence they have a lot of very strong
characteristics that make them not just
up cow or a pig they're just you know
their own Buttercup you know Julia fell
in love with cow she was basically giant
peach she was really long time favorite
bar customers a day cow um she was so
cute she kissed Julian a bunch I kissed
my arm I bought the whole st. Patrick
album Tuesday I'm probably salty that it
was due special mint and it was like it
was cool to hang out amongst the animals
in there like home you know I mean could
any time you drive by like a you know a
big pasture or whatever and you're like
you know be cool to go see all them but
they're not really like I don't know it
just felt like very like a sanctuary
felt like a home it's like they were all
happy with their house like they had
their play area they had their sleep
area they had walnut it was very cool it
was a cool experience and I would
definitely encourage any
who wants to go see an animal for any
reason to go check it out but maybe you
want it like that like a rainy day so
there's no other people there because
other people are pretty it was pretty
frustrating like you kids were running
around like parents weren't even like
telling their kids not to like run
around and like but I have any animals
that remain that was to be pet that's
not quite like the right way to say
because there's nothing wrong with kids
running around it was the fact that you
could tell that there is people there
especially even parents that we're using
it as a teachable moment for their kids
to show them like what a cow is and
where their food comes from and that we
need to respect them and you know all of
that and there were other parents that
were there with like groups of kids that
were clearly just trying to kill time on
a Sunday and didn't really care and/or
respect the fact that it's not a petting
zoo
you know it was like it felt like a lot
of the kids who didn't have any like
strong leadership in the parents or a
chaperone or guardian or whatever you
want to call it like it just felt like
they were there to be at a petting zoo
and that's like it's just so annoying
it's not a petting yeah and like a lot
of these animals were in horrible
situations before and now they're
rescued at the sanctuary so they're
allowed more like rehabilitating and
they're not quite ready to be around
that sort of energy or even be touched
you know to let you know like certain
animals you can't pet because they're
just not ready for it and it was well I
think the most annoying thing was just
the fact that there were a a lot of
people there and B you could clearly
tell the people that were there to visit
animals in a sanctuary and like we have
that you can take those people out and
that's the people who are there because
what let's instead of going to Disney
let's do something for a couple hours
and go cut some animals yeah you know
and it was like you know a lot of stuff
is hard to hear because there's like a
horse it's like has one eye it's just an
eye socket and like you know that
chicken laying on the ground that his
leg because he's more informed like
genetically modified and there's like
little kids almost stepping on this
chicken because it's laying on the
ground that's all I can do with his leg
up in the air and there's no parent
being like hey let's take a moment and
be respectful
it's a chicken laying on the ground in
front of you you know it was just like
man except there was a there was an emu
there named Earl and the you know every
animal that is out for like you know
visiting and saying hello there's a
volunteer who are all they were
fantastic our launches are very but
they'll tell you a little bit about the
animal and you know where they don't
like to be pet so people don't just jam
their hands in there
and she was like yeah Earl's are you
know our only EMU he doesn't like being
pet on a Bakker's feathers sometimes he
likes his neck rubbed but right now he's
taking a little nap and this grown-ass
man just walks in front and like punch
of face next to the email and like grab
it by its neck and start scratching it
for a picture I'm like sir this is not a
petting zoo like what the hell is wrong
with you like you know you don't want to
know about Earl you don't care about
early you just here you get a picture
with our oh boy yeah that was that was
the most frustrating thing you'd be
having like there was a lot of times
where I'd be having like a nice moment
like meeting a new animal that are not
are seeing really sweet animal that's
being nice to us or letting us hang out
and a lot of those moments were just
like violently interrupted by like an
annoying person being human being they
just didn't know how to be a respectful
person and was like either petting an
animal they shouldn't a pet or like
literally turning their head on like
away from their kids so their kids were
like chasing around this [ __ ] peak
playing thunder at cows people that peak
I was Amy crazy and this tootle most
horrible interior has a net because the
peacock has gotten out of its enclosure
which mind you is just like a simple
fence so obviously can jump up but
they're trying to keep them in there
yeah and so he's like God in it because
the peacock isn't he's like refusing to
go back he wants to come out and chill
in the main area yes so voluntarily gets
in it and there's kids just being like
oh my god it's a peacock and there's
like no parent no nobody being like hey
guys this uh this nice volunteer here is
trying to corral that peacock back in
those pens yeah if you could just step
back but the volunteer you can see is
playing looking at the kids look at the
peacock like should i net this peacock
and and like emotionally heat a pitch
these children or should I do my job and
get to see [ __ ] back in his pen
like hello ID I would need some help
right now this would be really helpful
if someone should just move the children
cuz I should use my net what it was
frustrating yeah for me for me I just
the emphasis is on having a tender
moment and having that be interrupted by
a shitty moment mm-hmm like we met these
three thousand pounds genetically
modified cows but they rescued from from
a slaughterhouse huge huge calf like I'm
a cow anything close to this big it was
actually kind of like disturbing damage
emails that are like anything bigger
than they should be in real life yes
namely gentleman he was like the size of
an elephant he was cute today was and I
just watched the movie yoga and sorry if
this is like a whole lot for you guys
right now you know we didn't we're not
trying to make this super-heavy podcast
but it was just it was a big moment like
you know no pun intended unlikely
discounters coming out it is intense and
then I see this girl and walk right up
to his leg and volunteers like oh my god
please don't do that like because she
had already said he has migrated to
Canada because he weighs 3,000 pounds
and he might like you know trip and sort
of fall around you you know overall I'm
happy I went it was an it's an
incredible place and they did an
incredible job I would love to go again
and maybe take a group of people that
are my friends and we can like rent rent
out because you can do parties and I
have the place yourself I don't know but
it was cool nonetheless I got to meet a
cow like I said I've walked most of it
there was a couple cute moments that
will be in the vlog tomorrow so you know
if you can't check out that but it was
one that has loss to this question as a
vegan did it help you to finally meet
the animals that in the past you had
eaten well we can out yeah we kind of
talked about this when we got back and
you were you basically were like you
know you've already been vegan for a
long time so it must feel pretty good to
go there after you've kind of been that
way for a while and have that reaffirmed
and that's true it did feel good and I
would just I would just say it's like a
reaffirming feeling like a lot of times
I'll think to myself about the choices
are making when it comes to I die and
why I'm making those choices and there
are definitely times when it is
definitely hard it's like it's a hard
because you
lose sight of like what exactly am I
trying to accomplish or why am i doing
this to that so today was all about
reaffirmation for me like it was meeting
these beings and kind of like having an
emotional connection with them which is
something I've never really pursued or
had the opportunity to do or created the
opportunity to do for myself I know the
opportunity's been there you know I've
lived in a lamp and then proximity that
place forever but it was it was very
reassuring it was a nice feeling of like
okay maybe this is why you're getting
that you know and that was a nice
feeling and that's something that I'll
always remember about today and I'll
take away for for a long time and um it
was a great like happy beast you know we
spend so much time with our dogs because
they make us happy but it you never
think about having that same happiness
come from other animals
I do like for me I've also has been a
spy of farm boys so if you won't be with
me you want to borrow your buy a farm
you already know that's my end game I
thought I was your farm boy farm you
said I want to buy a farm boy yeah no a
farm not a farm boy farm comma boy I was
just saying like after I went I'd never
I guess I've never been to an animal
sanctuary before I've been to some of
sorts but not for livestock animals what
were they like just chickens up how does
that live stuff that's why I suck I mean
I've been in sanctuaries for like
Julianne my kind of thing like zebra
yeah tour they like took them away from
a circus and then they put them in a
proper environment so they're not being
like speaking of zebra want to revisit
that comment from your Facebook oh yeah
so I this is been like sort of
mind-fucking me for like a week but on
my face look every Tuesday I post I'm
like hey just let me know what you guys
want to see for a video tomorrow because
I do always still although I hate
Facebook and I hate [ __ ] using it
it's the most cohesive way to lay that
out these tweets are sort of all of the
organizers come as well right so I still
to this day I always write on my
facebook every Tuesday the best that I
can like let me know what you want to
see because I do like people's input and
I do
like to make things people are
requesting never too often and in that
post I wrote like hey I'll just put some
zero it looks something goofy like I'm
gonna go to bed but hope you have a good
day let me know John say tomorrow and
one of the comments was claims to be
vegan drinks chemicals okay am I'm not
allowed to take medicine as a vegan I
don't know we're actually kind of
looking for insight here like you know
what they're talking about I'm not gonna
let take like advil like is that again I
don't get it
I like equal I mean I personally know
and then Julia made a joke zebras okay
so don't exist that's what he said it
was a joke though because it's obviously
not it's a sweet medicine over the
counter that doesn't have any animal
products or another animal products in
it it doesn't not that I'm aware but
like I understand that maybe that
person's thought process was like you
need a plant-based diet and so you take
plant-based medicine I don't know but
like with being a vegan doesn't mean
you're a homeopathic here we have
animatic treatments on medicine that's
what I'm saying like and I not want to
take Advil like and I now let have a
sore throat and like take a cough drop
I think they might have grouped it and
this isn't a thing that happens a lot
amongst stupid I'm saying a group will
Western medicine in with animal products
right like westernized medicine which is
like as equal well I'm sure there are
some men that has animal products in it
don't know know everything capsules no
no no what he was saying that they were
saying specifically is vegan drinks
chemicals okay hold on just a theory
are chemicals vegan I found something on
the web about your chemicals vegan
check it out little void series what
have you never matter like it I'm
nothing like I'm at a loss so well
comment below for a wrong and we're
crazy or believe you that person
anything
like I think I understand what they're
trying to say but like what are you
telling me like if I had a surgery like
I demand that no one use any type of
like you don't use any soap on me don't
use any antiseptic on me don't use any
no no pain killers no nothing don't
touch me no no anesthesia when I go to
the dentist I go to a a holistic dentist
that you know first they chime a bunch
of music around me and then they only
use colors to heal my cavities like I'm
really confused
we need no chemicals drinks chemicals or
knowledge drink chemicals genuinely
confused it like it's been my [ __ ] me
put-downs equal on drink some echinacea
okay see I don't know I'm honestly
confused by that I don't understand it
look if I clean my house I have to do it
with only water and like lemon juice and
vinegar and lemon juice is vegan
that's aguado reviewer for vinegar
anyway so no I was saying on I've been
to do other animal sanctuaries in the
past but never like a livestock animal
sanctuary and but I have because I'm
from upstate New York been to other
farms knew about them but they were like
you know on the weekends they would open
their family farm to the general public
which is like okay that as a kid you
know five people yeah and we've got in
there and they'd be like alright here's
a kitten we just like inside the La
Jolla cat now like MIT can I have four
cans guys hold it off let me just carry
around with you and then you go and you
meet the pigs and meet the piglets and
the cows and you know the gift shop you
know it's like their kitchen they're
selling you like their cheese their milk
their everything so they are a operating
farm that operates her a profit their
animals are there for a profit and
you're not working or not like they're
tired in the do meet them you do have an
experience with them it's not quite the
same as meeting animals that are like
this is their last hope they can't work
or you know but we met dairy cows that
you had terrible things happen to them
from being dairy cows yeah and you know
they would just be discarded or killed
yeah but they go to the gentle barn
because that's where they can live and
nothing doesn't happen
to them I don't know at these places
it's like these are currently working
animals and so the message is very much
like come and enjoy yourself on our farm
and this is how we make our milk and
where we make milk and these are our
pigs and you know we use them we
slaughter them to make bacon whatever
but it's a very different experience
going to an animal sanctuary
to where the message was at one point
like please don't bring any meat or
dairy out of the respect to the animals
and we have vegan hotdogs and would you
ever consider doing a plant-based diet
because it's you know once you're
exposed to that kind of thing
it's someone's going to be like hey
would you ever consider this and I need
support it's an important distinction to
make that the forms you talked about
visiting growing up - small family-owned
farms where they have ten cows making
Garry and whatever you don't mean like a
small amount it's not a huge office
there is a big difference between that
and then me and dairy industry where
they have slaughterhouses and factory
farming I mean obviously we can go on
and argue about this all all day long
around just I just think it's an
important distinction of man yet that
there are certain farms that aren't just
like evil evil everywhere right but I
think that there's certainly a lot of
people that go to a place like the
gentle barn that are thinking to
themselves like oh man all these animals
are abused like this is so sad this was
so great for rescuing them but the
animals that are you know abused a lot
of them are just animals that were in
the meat and dairy industry normal
animal right they just survive yeah you
know I mean look they don't make the
connection it's not like some evil jerk
in his basement beating up a cow over
and over again and then he ends up with
the Gentle Barn yeah like this is a
dairy cow that was forced have babies
over and over and over and almost killed
- yeah I mean yeah but it is it's
interesting that when you go to an
animal sanctuary the message is very
different than when you go to a family
farm and the message is like this is
where your food comes from and glad you
had a good time
so keep buying our meat dairy yeah you
know yeah
it was it was really cool and we'll all
like the gentle arm below if you guys
ever want to check it out it's a cool
place or any animal sanctuary or any
animals are just cool it
because it's great date but speaking of
animals we recently met a full-size
greyhound on one of our walks his name
is tightened and we immediately said to
each other we want to get a great no
we've been saying that oh yeah I know
but every time we need one it becomes
like at the top of our list video so
then we were like we can't have one in
this house we need to get a house first
then we could get a greyhound so for the
second half of the talk I'm not working
towards the house for a lot of years
we've been working hard to happen and
we're going to get one eventually but
maybe maybe we can speed it up we get
speeding it up today okay they got us
some water
tickets yo we got $88 what the script we
is waiting spend eighty eight dollars on
these a lot of tickets okay guys we're
going to scratch them up okay and
hopefully we only man I got hopefully we
get a dog and you know what guys if you
don't have the disposable money ran to
go do this it's okay because right now
you can sign up for the skin calm and
it's Jenna Jo and you can be answered
with a two hundred fifty or Visa gift
cards which you guys spend on model
thing well I know what we are we have
you could win that right now all you
guys do is go to this time calm that's
th e sk IMM dot-com fashion Angeline
what is this Kim you asked
oh that's I know the answer okay it is a
lot of stuff going on in this world it
has new stories everywhere jumbled and
far they are jumbled and fell here what
the skin does is it takes all the
important info
consolidates it packs it up nice and
tight too and like this big oh my god
sends it to your email inbox for no cost
at all all that all the important things
you need to dominate the conversations
at work okay dominate them do not let
another person get a word in read the
scale if it is you find up right now and
thank me later it's free guys it's not a
free trial we have to pay later it's
free always coming at the watercooler
Karen okay someone's telling us a little
arias the skin makes it easy for you to
be smart with the latest on world news
politics sports and entertainment takes
all the top issues and puts it into
easy-to-read email all right guys I'm
telling you you should do it go to the
skimmer
it's free all right you learning of the
bindings goetta th es ki mmm calm /g o
Julian those are our names and you
signed up right to subscribe but you're
also entered for a chance to win a $250
Visa gift card which you could possibly
also spend on a lot of tickets and then
once you you get the lotto tickets right
and you buy the dog but you don't lose
your dog you get a tracker right you
just put the track on the doggie David
Segway within it and the dog will
forever be trapped by the tracker app
and the tracker device okay it's very
helpful what did the tracker guys it is
a tiny little client-side device that
you can track your belongings if you
don't so lose your keys your wallet your
phone your backpack your dog anymore
because you have the tracker eight years
ago tracker changed everything when they
release their first tracking device and
now they've done it again with the new
tracker pixel it's even smaller it's
sexier it works better it's amazing okay
when you lose an item ahead the tracker
pixel attached use your smartphone and a
90 decibel alert will help you find it
in seconds it even even has a powerful
LED light so you can find it in the dark
you can even find yourself if it's miles
away because every tracker user is part
of the largest crowd network in the
world my tracker pixel makes my life
easy when I travel for last-minute trips
I put one in the drone bag I put one in
my bag I carry on okay my bag nothing is
getting taken from me because I will
find you it when I find you I will
dominate the conversation your back
right now go does a tracker that's th e
TR ACK are calm use promo code Jenna
Julian to get 20% off any order guys
it's a small device that can make a big
difference I highly recommend it check
it out thank you now let's get to
scratchin oh my god
wait no Kay let's get it on because I
don't feel like we fully clarified the
logic why we do this so in our current
house right now which we rent we've
lived here for like 3 years 2 months old
III yeah and people are supposed to use
blood how smooth it's very expensive a
lot of you guys know that and we have
been working it's not like we're not
working towards the house we are we want
to do it in the right way we want to get
a house that suits our needs and our
future needs
and our current landlord charges us per
dog
per month yeah we're kind of getting
boned pretty hard right now renting this
house but $3 right recusing for even
still he was like I think that we told
him about ads but I don't think that
there's anything exclusive us ever know
what to have a before I wrote it when I
rather we're not allowed to have a
fourth dog like that the reason we're
allowed to have three and in the past
that have had to pay extra data combined
weighs nothing
right looks like a combined weight of 35
pounds yeah but it's really a mess
because because they're not big they're
all small but if we got a big dog than
that totally changes it and I don't know
land loads are legally a lot I know
there's people citing that law about
people legally allowed being allowed to
have X amount of dogs like a know the
cap is like four or five or something in
the same California yeah but that they
can't like you know charge you extra and
do [ __ ] up [ __ ] just because you have
a dog I heard that people are trying to
fight that law yeah um but basically
someday when we like finally save up and
do it or you know when somebody wins you
at all today
our first thing is we're going to get a
full-size rack it's our green light to
finally adopt a raised marry you yeah
and when we actually have been
researching this owners Asian called
gray phase yeah about tighten the one we
just met is from Gracie yeah she was
like she was like oh you guys want
adopted a animals like yeah she's like
oh I got him from grain save and I was
like girl you do not know how also not
browse that website you mean my home
page very good darlin all right so I got
Lotteria
Don Clemente where you set for life win
four thousand dollars a month for 25
years so we spent $88 we did a lot of
money go a lot of owners and never ever
ever ever
so we're splurging I guess you'd say so
I gotta figure out mine work and if we
win something I don't know
and what do we have to win in order to
get a house what happened to my calling
oh I see okay so
Koller cards okay so it's not personal
for quieter in Spanish because it's a
rotary yeah okay I'll implement it all
right I have to scratch off the caller
cards one bonus caller card to reveal 15
symbols then I scratch the corresponding
symbols on the Lotteria cards using that
match the caller card symbols match all
four symbols and a complete horizontal
or vertical line in a lot of rear card
to win a prize my ninja numbers you just
scratch mindlessly anyways while we are
doing this so Julian oh we want to talk
about a new show we are watching okay
guys we're trying to win a dog okay
return win our dog we did enjoy a weird
dog but while we do this which you're
not you're sitting here watching a
scratch so I got a shrimp with that we
watch your show we finish the Jenna
finish I haven't seen one episode it's
called the wheel called the wheel and
there's a we know that's not the right
theme song is a premise of the wheel
matter six people five or six five six
six people to volunteer to be on the
show and basically what they did is they
dropped six people into the six most
extreme climates of South America there
was the tundra the mountains the
wetlands the pressing the first plane
was planes and there's one more whatever
they were all very gnarly like
alligators in the wetlands and the bush
planes and then they had the mountain
which was like snowing at some points in
the mountain lines it was crazy and
these people had to survive it's
actually kind of a funny show being sick
so it's like a survivor like today win
nothing with the free app really nothing
ever yeah anyway we were watching and
this dude's what was his name weeks
who's an absolute beast at surviving
like he was man he wasn't in to begin
houses he was hunting and not the
beginning but towards the end you
started watching her like oh this that's
great you're like damn leukemia - [ __ ]
yeah so basic oh I see I don't even
subscribe okay basically
he's at the wetlands and he's hungry
right so he's like [ __ ] what do I eat
turns out there's a whole [ __ ] like
swath of caiman which are basically
alligators in this like swamp right near
his camp so like maybe I should just go
like hunt one of these Caymans and like
kill an alligator and eat it
and we watched him and he was actually
doing it he walked over and he ended up
actually killing like a baby alligator
and eating it it was crazy but we were
watching this episode and we were joking
around because it was so funny because
we were like imagine for one of the
other alligators just like sitting there
watch him like take your friend and like
eat him in front of you and we like
we're like they're probably like look
boy over there eaten Jamie Keil share it
coming in my and anybody seen Jarrod
this boy Williams smells like boy cute
cuz that's like you he can do it Oh
we'll go get yours male now here's so
funny
um but yeah that's that's like though
that was like our favorite jerk of the
show I don't know how to tell if I want
okay so we this is very confusing babe
the tree the barrel heart the response
is going on away
Julianne I'm trying to win a dog the
crown okay crown boot I wish you did
just hair not just a lottery ticket
you're just waiter dog spider spider we
got spider umbrella we got umbrella what
the hell the parrot did we have a parent
I have one absolutely nothing okay I
didn't went on this always drum
watermelon lady babe I don't know what
the [ __ ] you got you know it's funny I
need melon candy melon Oh guys I want
another ticket
did you really oh yeah it just says
ticket Oh where's rooster I mean okay I
lost that one this one that's and chat
s-s-san chatter what's going out that
pub G Invitational thing oh so I think
it's basically pub G getting officially
like involved in eSports
can anyone compete in it I think you
have to qualify qualified okay all right
maybe maybe King season energy wise or
solo you're doing it wrong I have
playlist for everything why don't you
try to quality if I absolutely get so
Murchison I would love to watch you get
murked I love you too um whenever
Blizzard Blizzcon does that like
hearthstone tournament I'm like man how
do I [ __ ] do that I want to play
hearthstone in a giant stage and watch
people [ __ ] laugh at me as I lose and
get my ass beat I'll do them one away
from us 3.30 thousand dollar prize I
missed it though I missed it check again
the fish a mandolin man I'm got me
trying to win a greyhound it probably
cost like slightly more to actually
adopt them than it does to buy these
tickets let it doesn't buy us a new
landlord cactus it doesn't make us our
own landlords yep hey dot yeah that's
right so if we get a new dog sometimes
they come with memes I would never
change their name but if we got to name
them doing what would you want it where
you want a girl doing wants another girl
oh yeah one another girl what would you
name a big girl Greyhound Jame private
school girl
no just you me Jillian Jay a apostrophe
m AI to me did you tell them how they
how you spelled Jared they eatin Jared
and Jared is Jay ARA ad that's why you
soldier this is hard to multi-task with
he's like double check DS wait I am I'm
super easy oh okay I'm 130 doesn't it
wait why do you live where do you win
for life BRB I'm gonna win 30 doesn't
aspire
a bonnet oh I have to I have to uncover
a life symbol no I didn't mean
automatically win $4,000 a month for 25
years that's pretty healthy I like that
yeah what if I lived more than 25 years
as usual estate yes I'm gonna be 55
oh okay speaking of a guys are super
[ __ ] up
yes hello it's [ __ ] me [ __ ] me before
Brooklyn ah so you know like when you're
a senior in high school and they do like
they usually throw your you throw
yourself I guess I guess some sort of
senior bash or party or whatever before
you graduate yeah
are you listening yeah I'm listening hi
hello
I had grad night it was my vs. yeah I am
listening so I love you um for ours the
other thing called a lock-in where we
all fade up for like a whole night and
we have no - it was a grab net you stay
up the whole night yeah and you're like
in the gym in the cafeteria and there's
like activities and stuff and yeah
what's going on over there $30 I was
like this close I'm listening okay I
feel like if we win $30 we should send
this to a dink fan member right I just
the first Catherine Jascha ticket just a
tease okay I'm down um we have this
thing called a lock-in and you know his
activities all night or whatever and in
the cafeteria at one point like my best
friend's mom was a psychic and she was
there but she didn't do my reading this
other lady did my reading and they were
psychic I'm listening and so she's like
giving me a normal reading like you know
saying whatever [ __ ] and then she
was like do you want to know how you're
gonna die oh my god oh my god oh my god
no no she actually didn't even say that
she was she told me like when I was
going to get married how many kids I was
gonna have and I forgot all of that
obviously because then she just out of
the blue was like you're gonna die when
you're 65 in a foreign land oh my god
or maybe she said in years 60 I'm not
quite sold on science I was turning
exactly remember it your general brain
shambles but she like told me that I was
going to die like in my 60s
hello you know foreign land and no no
she's just that in a foreign land where
and I said what does that mean there she
goes it's just somewhere that's not your
home oh okay so I get like I'm [ __ ]
pissed because I feel like no psychics
should really ever tell you that unless
you like explicitly go sorry
if they even could tell when you were
going to die but this girl told me or
this woman told me when I was 17 years
old when I was going to die and not how
or anything yeah but if it's been like
really annoying and it pisses me off
that she said that was really [ __ ]
inappropriate and even when I went and
did the thing with the psychic twins I
was like okay can you guys clear
something up for me because when I was
in high school this psychic told me that
I was gonna die in my 60s in a foreign
land and they were like no no no
psychics should ever [ __ ] say that
it's terrible
you mean and it's like it makes me angry
but it actually sometimes really helps
me like when we're flying and I hate
flying it really scares me I don't like
it and there's like a lot of turbulence
or something dramatic is happening a
microphone oh no no this is now how I
died everything is fine because I'm
going to die in my sixties in a foreign
land everything is fine
it's not annoying yeah you know I just
told you like I get away well you know
why I mean especially the psycho twins
you know much about them but honey so
what this IQ to it oh you just don't
think that I want another ticket you
want to know this thing I haven't won
anything
what happened to it was a technical
difficulties sorry about that guys
oh boy um more technical difficulty than
you playing with the headphone so the
first three minutes of this podcast
there's no such thing as more technical
difficulty than that
oh I haven't won anything it's not even
the ticket boot umbrella
I want to ticket though we're circling I
want the doors and windows what went
indoors how are we gonna get a dog with
$10 I need to win for life for $10
something and you know more than one
winning on one ticket yeah I think so
wait what I do it oh I'm losing stuff
what it like terrible way to win a dog
why can't you just uncover a greyhound
and it says you win a dog and you're
your own landlord right well we're ten
dollars up are we up any long sign out
okay I mean this really isn't even a
good way to gamble like not even like an
effective gambling like you feel about
the word again yeah actually you're like
you're pretty good at blackjack watch a
good song for me
the more I play for fun the more I win
the more I try to win money the less I
win yeah true because when we were there
in Vegas with Chris and them left who
watch oh yeah yeah I want a lot of money
because I was just like having fun yeah
literally not even trying to win yeah I
feel like if you're one of those people
that like stays up all night trying to
win all their money back you just you
end up farther in the hole yeah that's a
dangerous game you gotta have a cassette
a lot of money and then stop after that
mm-hmm definitely you know every it's
really sad when he sees we'll just like
lose all their money and then they don't
know how to stop or when it's car Sosa
guys get eighty eight dollars and go sit
on a bunch of crappy scratch tickets a
never gonna get you the dog true hit
like for real though we're not going to
name a dog Jame I can't we numerous
ahjimmae can you explain to them that
reference at least someday you know I'm
so good on it's a quick really show is
this a boring podcast I don't know it's
a Chris Lilley show so they never know
what's a boring podcast
Chris really because they're incredible
comedian and Ozzy he's Ozzy right I
think so and he made a bunch of shows of
his characters he did one of the most
generic rival girl was just like rich
girl and hit with him playing with draw
it was just one of the times crazy
spending so funny legendary for
legendary adventure
may not Jame what would you name a
full-size Giant Peach basically probably
a little more mellow than peachy because
you're gonna get them not as a puppy
yeah arranged you something goofy like
um Tour polar Julien no okay no you like
trolled me in my own video when you said
that my little half face was torkoal and
then someone tweeted me like a Julianne
good officer Parks and Rec reference and
I was like boy so what what's wrong an
officer a person reference you like
Parks and Rec
oh [ __ ] y'all would you win we don't get
it what'd you win three dollars
I thought you actually won money [ __ ]
yeah right oh dammit
like do you ever like once in a blue
moon though just really get the urge to
do like a scratch ticket no too bad I
just won five dollars oh I want three
dollars and a ticket on the same card
damn now I can lose to two more times I
like to make up my own rules of these
tickets and then bring them back into
the shadows claiming prettier ones they
just scan the barcode and it does some
weather no I'll have them skin when I
was in debt and I don't understand oh no
I like I like scratching a lottery
ticket actually like Quattroporte a rush
okay we were wrong don't be nasty I
actually used to play them every once in
a while when I was in Boston and then I
would save them in my glove box and my
glove compartment in my car or if ever I
was like because I didn't have any money
visually ever that was also back when
Bank of America if you overdo your bank
account by like 50 cents and recharging
$35 every single time and so I was
really [ __ ] I would go into that red
sometimes and I would save them in my
glove box in case I needed like laundry
money or like emergency money with
Delphis cash some of my little like $5
winnings and be like hell yeah I'm gonna
be fun ballin on a hook good idea though
yeah like cash if I had any at the time
yeah and it's like a small purchase that
could when you big it's true
you know mm-hmm this is so maybe if we
win the million dollars in fun to utopia
to start up again okay guys that's what
we've got on how we're talking we're
scratching them so that we can fund
utopia mm-hmm this is utopia
let's make up in where we facetiming
with room and colony other day when he
said that when Bowie grows up it doesn't
seem like fo you watch utopia really
maybe didn't wanna I think it was a joke
I mean why why the show just you're
setting yourself up to be disappointed
because it ends up one season midnight
not full season it ends after half a
seat yeah these are duds okay I was in
Utopia anyways in the comments below why
don't you guys leave me some of your
favorite cancelled TV show that's good
alright that's loud [ __ ] boy what's your
favorite canceled TV show during that
zone is going to be saying oh that's
such a good one that was a bo burnham
show on MTV it was [ __ ] hysterical
smart for our own good it was all
because I think so at the time was you
know so pretty young-hee so for young
but it was like I was such a good show
they had it they made it probably in the
hopes that it would take off with that
demographic like teenage girls but it
was [ __ ] it was brilliant and it was
a great [ __ ] show yeah it was really
really good
a manifesto back stone is gonna be
famous if any of you have watched it you
know what we're talking about man so
it's geisha what else what else did you
like they got cancelled um Jersey Shore
but I hear there's a reunion happening
and I'm not someone's there's rumblin is
it a noun so I think it's re they've
been pictures of them yeah already
pretty much announced I would love to
see that I love Suzy show even though
they're all like older and have families
and silver and modest I kind of agree
with you
I've said that I want wear a Jersey
Shore is more Jersey Shore is more to be
sure even if it's boring I'm cool with
it well the last season was such a
bummer and I hate that they ended on
that because it was like there's so many
good moments before the last season and
then lot seasons is just like how to put
these pregnancies to live here Oh
mics over oh no one's really doing
anything yeah let me run a sword
together but what all right now like it
was just there was nothing it was like
man season season five wasn't
seasons I wasn't it wasn't so what do
you think this season would be I think
it's going to be a lot of well spent
either mom but I don't think she's
talking right anymore
you know just for when they filmed I
don't know maybe she was on oh thanks
Ally well she can drink that but I said
all of them are like grown adults it's
not going to be the same as them being
like welcome to rewind one years old and
my concentration of doing backflips in
their underwear like what the hell
when do they do that look at you should
like do cartwheels
cuca quotas Oh hmm okay okay all right
I'm striking out here I may have won $15
guys obviously it looks like we're just
gonna have to keep working towards this
great house listen wasn't here and it
wasn't here guys no corners to cut life
is there jack
wait a minute Tim a clean room how do
you have your winning you do on that
crown can you come down a few crowns
no ground wow you did not have to do
that is your master you have to like
line up objects and very difficult steps
really cleaning some line up objects so
like these objects you have to have
these in your key box and you have to
line them up so I'm right there okay
right here you remember that vine no
let's go dad I whatever she's like [ __ ]
someone else one no it's like bingo yeah
yeah yeah
oh I do remember that line that's funny
yeah this one is but add 150 dollars out
of all of us $15 you're doing better
than I I won uh three dollars and a
ticket to take it checkin move two more
times
you're gonna help you out over there
you can let me down one more time what
was that bro they were talking about it
that's a joke I want blank to lower me
into my grave so they usually let me
down one more time
what's it mean bury your means how does
this work can't just scratch off the
dollar signs women if you uncover easier
yeah hell yeah it is what I'm trying to
win me a [ __ ] Greyhound like that
article that said that Millennials
aren't saving their money to buy homes
for babies or marriage they're saving
money to buy homes for their dogs and I
was like I responded I was like our
generation is dope yo I won five dollars
oh yeah I've won a total of eight
dollars and a ticket to take it when do
these correspond to each other like if I
know Oh every ticket is different every
time like that's literally what I'm
doing right now I'm scratching off
scratch to get stronger so I could win
another dog I struck out again I struck
out again in society is that the last
one I have one yes fine all right guys
well we didn't win 30,000 or nor did we
win sometimes for twenty-five thousand
eight dollars I won fifteen whoa what's
that combined 23 oh wow okay we sorts
any eight nine is 2355
you know this is like one of our more
expensive odd cast it is 55 55
what the hell man expensive we spent 65
Elvis's budget
to do nothing thank you guys for
watching the podcast I wanted to win a
grand winner great so you're saying I'm
just going to have to keep smoking my
money to buy a dog we got to get gray on
Scott just to the ground
all right here's a new idea scratch
tickets for adoptable animals who's
going to fund this me but we have to win
scratch tickets to fund it correct
all right well I like that yeah if we're
not here next week it's because we're
chasing our dreams and trying to create
a stretch to get rid of you but you
could win like a like a ball python and
they're like and when you win you don't
get a choice the animal shows up at your
house in the water it's yours
and if it's and if it's barrel it's
feral right marbles no just attack you
like Mama's not feral is a real guy he
always keeps going mobile Farrell
Farrell guys make sure your pets are
fair okay I want a big gray house
imagine some day when you're watching
the gener doing podcast and you know
climate doing Dylan I had a ferret named
Dylan what was a girl that's what you
did
can't name a giant dog going I have a
dead parrot named Dylan I loved her I
used to feed her banana every morning no
but imagine you're watching the Jenna
Dewan podcast and there's just like a
goofy little face because she's sitting
right here she's like she's sitting
upright Monogram thank you guys so much
for hanging out with this stuff
hopefully you got something editors did
hopefully you got one $15 or $24 if
anything guys don't buy these cacio guys
make it right wait do they have been
doing YouTube channels where you I buy
$200 for this trip scratching it's it's
not like a thing that went around I
don't know it doesn't work okay so we
really spent the money so you don't have
to we spent eighty eight dollars that we
could have saved it for our future dog
all right guys we'll see this I want to
win a dog all right I eat and my
[Music]
[Music]